okay so my screen is shared right yes it
is
okay very good okay so yeah so I will
now talk about basically zero knowledge
proof and its application so the
applications are two commitments and
signatures and I think this is an area
that's just sort of getting started in
lattice cryptography sort of getting
started being efficient being useful so
I the talk is kind of an overview of
what we've been doing so this is really
recent progress so this stuff is stuff
that's really the works I'm talking
about that are some of them are really
either in submission or just in
preparation
so it's write fairly new and so I will
give an overview of what we've been
doing and then Gregor will the second
talk will give the details of the
concrete sort of the key constructions
that sort of go into this work okay so I
will start with an overview and then go
into zero knowledge so okay okay okay
right so lattice problems I mean I guess
you've heard of two about two of them
there's a little nuances right so but I
don't sort of as a sort of practical
purposes I don't like to think of them
as two problems I sort of think of them
as one right you just write them as the
Kanab sac problem and that really
encompasses both LW answers so just
think of a matrix a you're given an
integer matrix a and T and into the
matrix a and the vector T and you know
the goal is to find an S with small
coefficients so that a s equals T mod Q
right so this is a knapsack problem over
vectors so and this is really both lwe
insists so if you've seen sis
then so if you haven't seen Albion
system this is the problem right then
don't even care what they are this is
the lattice problem that the harwood
hardness all things are based on so if
you've seen sis well this is the
inhomogeneous version of it the
homogeneous one has T equals 0 and if
you haven't seen this before
and why is this like lwe well it's sort
of simple right because now I have a s
equals T but this is equivalent to just
multiplying by a special matrix B on
both sides so that one side one part of
a becomes the identity right so it's the
B is the inverse of some part of a so
then it's equivalent to a concatenate
with the identity times s equals this T
Prime and then if you want you can split
out the s into s 1 and s 2 so it becomes
a prime times s 1 plus s 2 so s 1 is the
secret as 2 is the error so it's really
ugly
so so I'm not going to make a
distinction between these two most well
the top I will just say this is the
knapsack problem and all sort of
practical a descriptor is based on
something something of that sort
right how a is chosen is may be
sometimes different for n truth shows in
a different way but from the for our
intents this is the this is the problem
with considering okay so now the
hardness of it let's consider it as a
one-way function okay so let's say
you're given this a and the the function
is f of S is a s mod Q and the problem
is to find the smallest prime may not be
the same as s just to invert the
function so that F of S prime equals T
right so how hard is this problem this
is the central problem so how hard is it
well I sort of like to draw this this
very inexact I mean there is no that
ignore the slopes and it's just going up
means it's harder going down it's easier
right so it all depends on the norm of s
right so if everything is else is fixed
the dimension is fixed then the norm of
s is what makes a difference so if the s
is very small it's one-way function then
the function is injective and this is
the lwe probe then as s grows becomes
larger larger and larger the problem
gets harder harder and harder until the
point where kind of a times s is an onto
function and this is this so basically
and then it becomes easier and easier
and easier so a B you should intuitively
write if there's no restriction on s the
size of s is really big then this
problem is very easy right just use
Gaussian elimination so
and really the the hardness of this
knapsack problem looks like this so at
some point it gets harder harder harder
the bigger asses and then it becomes
easier so ideally what we would love to
do is to build schemes that are based on
the hardest version this is exactly
where it's sort of injected almost
injected for it and if the domain of s
is the same as the domain of the
function as the range of the function
but you know you can't do it you because
we have other constraints so you know
for example encryption schemes you
cannot build it based on this this you
know a function that's on to because you
won't have correctness signature schemes
you can't base it here because they
won't have soundness so you have
problems like that so you know you
cannot always be based it on top but you
know you will end up basing it on one
side or the other maybe or even on both
and then it will be people say this is
our W e and this is sis right that's
really it's just in that sector okay so
and now knapsack problems are really
lattice problems because if you can find
a short vector in the integer lattice
with dimension m and determine in Q to
the N ignore the determined parts are
important then you can solve the
knapsack problem so basically finding a
short vector in a lattice of dimension N
or a close factor again I'm not making
this distinction so this is practical
lattice crypto so almost all of it is
done over polynomial ring so not over
the integers but over rings so the Rings
we're going to working with is the Z X
mod f of X so if you've never seen this
before I'll just do a quick example of
what what this ring is so it has
addition and multiplication right so
let's let's do the sample ring Z 17 X
mod X to the fourth plus one so what
this means is that all operations you
have modular reduction mod 17 and also
modular reduction X to the fourth plus
one so all elements in this ring you can
think of the rid of representatives as
basically polynomials of degree three
right and whose coefficients are
integers mod 17 so to add two
polynomials you just coordinate wise add
Paulino
and do reduction about seventy but to do
multiplication well it's also the usual
polynomial multiplication but now the
degree of the polynomial can become
bigger than four and then you have to do
a reduction Matt X to the fourth plus
one so here's an example I mean you can
trust me at all I don't know if it works
look it from very old slides it needs to
work yeah you multiply these two
polynomials you get something without
any reduction and then you start
subtracting off multiple then you sort
of start writing X to the fourth is my
minus 1 right and eventually you end up
with a polynomial of degree 3 and that's
it right so something very important is
that if you look at the polynomial on
top without without reduction mod 4 and
1 on the bottom
reductions mod 4 do not increase X to
the fourth plus 1 do not increase the
coefficients too much right so for some
mod you life if it wasn't X to the 4
plus 1 there could be actually an
exponential increase modeling by this f
of X but back to the 4 plus 1 there is
not and this is very useful for crypto
right that for the cryptography that
we're doing a reduction mod this
polynomial f of X does not increase the
coefficients too much okay so now
instead of defining lattices over Z you
can define them you know at least this
knapsack problem over Z you can define
it over any other ring so now let's say
this polynomial f of X is some point O
me with degree D and now instead of a
being in Z and by M it's now in our M by
M and s is in RM with small coefficients
so and not much has changed except we're
multiplying elements in R instead of and
we're still doing 1 right so now the in
term that we want to sort of think about
the hardness of this problem the
hardness of this problem now increases
by the dimension of the polynomial right
so if you want to find a short solve
this knapsack problem this now becomes
as hard as finding a short vector in an
integer in an integer lattice so not
over the ring anymore
of dimension D times F so whenever we
sort of we try to find short vectors the
we convert the lattice the lattice kind
of automatically gets converted to an
integer lattice no matter where it
started I mean it start maybe it started
as a as a lattice over some other ring
but as an additive group it's the it has
an equivalent representation over the
integers but now the dimension of it is
d times m and determinant is also bigger
by a factor of D in the exponent so so
basically if you see an N by M relation
or a knapsack problem over a ring of you
know defined by a polynomial of degree D
then as a lattice problem it's dimension
is d times okay all right so now um this
is all sort of old stuff so why are we
using polynomial rings well you know we
we may be over to more than ten years
ago you know we know that there's these
reductions that say that well if you can
solve average-case problems this
knapsack problem for random a you can
actually solve worst case problems over
some ring z x 1 f of X right so the same
kind of worst case average case
reduction that we know persist and lwe
exists for seasonably over polynomial
grades so the one thing we these
reductions don't tell us right is how
should we choose f of X and Q right
because the the hard problem does depend
on f of X so how should they be how
should they be chosen and I mean
unfortunately the reductions don't say
anything about anything interesting
about f of X it says they should be
reducible multiplication might f of X
should not increase coefficients too
much but otherwise there's no guidance
so it definitely is an open question
whether some f of X could make the
problem easy right
so far not much has happened there's
been some interesting work for a very
large queue that I mean that keeps
coming up but so far I there's not much
you know
but but definitely it's not because we
have some sort of a reduction that we
haven't been successful in solving a
short vector problems for different f of
X it's the reduction doesn't say
anything about that right so yeah so
right unfortunately there's nothing
there but the reductions are kind of
useful when it comes to picking q and
the reductions basically say it doesn't
matter right they work for any q and of
course you know that they are asymptotic
reduction so it's not quite clear as to
really the concrete hardness but again
you know some people who just backed out
maybe four different q if the f of X
Factor is a lot mod Q it becomes easier
but no no there's always these magical
defenses built in to the algebraic
structure that that sort of that
prevents all these attacks and I myself
also as you know is suspicious of some
cues but no there's really nothing there
you should really here I'd really trust
the reduction so as far as my personal
opinion I you know which f of X is hard
I think they're all hard but I really
have no reason to think that just
because there's no crypt analysis but in
terms of once you make an f of X what
should the q beef I think any Q should
be okay so which which of them since the
reductions will don't say much what you
should do which do we use in practice
and here for efficiency some popular
choices are f of X and X of D plus one
remember it has to be irreducible over
the integers so when D is a power of two
this is an irreducible over the integers
and Q we choose a Q so that X to the D
plus one has low degree factors so it's
excellent D plus 1 mod Q actually splits
maybe completely or small so much as
fact is a small degree so the reason we
do this is because there is this X to
the D plus 1 polynomial has it very
smoothly stay very small coefficient
growth but modding by it and if it
factors you can have really really fast
operations like multiplication using the
number theory transform so it's like the
FFT but over by it
so another popular choice especially in
fhe is X to the D plus 1 and you take da
power of 2 but Q is also a power of 2
and here you are
these coefficient growth and pretty easy
mod Q representation and operations so
that's enough but you cannot use entity
at least not direct and other otherwise
f of X is cyclotomic for example so it
doesn't have to be X to the D plus y I'm
just some other cyclothymic that has
many of the same properties like the D
plus 1 so these are some of the you know
if you care about efficiency these are
the choice these are the things that get
used most are okay but you know is it
what if we don't really care about
efficiency too much I mean so what
what about algebraic structure right so
so it passed doesn't hasn't really come
into play when you consider basic
constructions like signatures and
encryption we do want to choose this
special f of X and we do want to choose
this Q so you can use efficient
multiplication but it's not really super
crucial right so I mean you could have
things maybe it'll be twice as slow but
you can use you know different f of X
and Q right so the point is that the
algebraic structure of f of X does not
really come into play in these
construction in basic constructions this
we don't really use the algebraic
structure of f of X now when we move on
to something more interesting like for
example hash and science signatures and
trapdoor sampling so we talks about it
on Wednesday then you really want
because of the way this these efficient
algorithms for sampling work you really
want the cyclotomic f of X where M has
very few distinct small factors sort of
like X to the D plus 1 is very good when
D is a power 2 because there only has
one distinct small effect the Q still
doesn't matter too much
I mean verification we fast this with
ntt if you use an IQ that splits the f
of X but again it really doesn't matter
so in practice though you're like
anything other than X the D plus 1 makes
the sampling algorithm really
complicated so we did we did that for
one of our new submissions and then
people took it out the other people the
other partners to get out say no this is
way weight even though the second
simplest polynomial to use became way
too complicated for this this algorithm
so peer
let's maybe xsv plus one is is the right
thing to use but Q doesn't matter then
we move on to fully homomorphic
encryption and that'll be talks on
thursday to friday so there you do want
the cyclotomic f of X the Q doesn't
matter too much and there are some
trade-offs for different queues and the
reason is because you know your you know
your plain text is not really working
about Q your ring is not Q but your
plain text is mod p which is smaller
than Q and then you want to have many
these see a Chinese remainder slots of f
of X mod in f of X mod p so f of X
should split mod p a lot and then you
can have arithmetic operations mod p and
things like that so that's why you want
a cyclotomic so you can so it can split
nicely into linear factors mod p but the
Q does not matter too much
and then there's zero knowledge proof
and some application so that's this talk
and here at least the with the way we'll
be describing things is you really do
want the cyclotomic f of X so so I mean
so we'll fix that of X DX D plus 1 and
here you do want the Q where where this
where this f of X actually splits in a
particular way so and the reason is very
similar to the reason for fhe because we
do want these Chinese remainder slots
for arithmetic operations but also we
want further algebraic structure and
order some water morphisms will be
useful and sometimes you may not even
want to split into linear factors you
may want to have factors that are
slightly larger so here so I would say
here is right now the area where
algebraic structure really really
matters of pi X where is so here you do
want to pick Phi X and Q so you know the
point here is that I feel that if we
want something to sort of support the
most number of schemes maybe you do want
to sort of concentrate on choosing this
f of X B that's the D plus 1 and
choosing a Q so that this f of X kind of
splits right so the tailor to
f of X if we only cared about encryption
and signatures it wouldn't really matter
at all I would say almost and you know
this these are this is what's going on
with this competition now people are
saying you know what should you use this
f of X this Q or this f of X this Q it
doesn't matter too much but it really
begins to matter once you move to more
complicated construction so I think
there really is a lot of a lot of good
reasons to study some particular F of
X's on Q's
so buddy a couple of quick questions
it's with you when you said to refer you
know small expansion factor in other
words multiplication doesn't increase
coefficients by very much when you said
that is that important for security or
is it important for correctness so it's
kind of it becomes a bit of a cycle
right so it first becomes important for
correctness and then if you want
correctness now you have to increase
your Q and then it becomes sort of in
less secure so then you have to then
increase thing to get correctness so you
end up losing efficiency so it's it's
it's that so there's always a lot of
says you can always do anything with
anything almost but we always leads to
some vicious cycle order of increasing
this parameter then you increase this
parameter and put the fern until at some
point yeah so so you're saying roughly
that if I pick any irreducible and how
facts and essentially any if I don't
care about efficiency concrete
efficiency just polynomial efficiency I
can pick any irreducible f of X and any
Q and that should be no no I mean there
are some f of X that really if you mod
by this F of XT can exponentially grow
you're okay so f of X cannot use that's
why I didn't write doesn't matter I
wrote doesn't matter much yeah so so any
reducible with a small expansion factor
expansion factor less than 2 to the N
maybe should be what okay so if there is
no reason for you to pick an f of X with
with such a large thing I mean if you
want one particular algebraic structure
either there's many
many good ones that you can pick them
there's no reason to just for fun you
know it's not fun it's really not fun if
you start setting parameters for these
so the second question is sir maybe this
is jumping ahead a little bit but uh but
there are sort of bring independent you
know another word say yeah I know I
think some of one of it is yours
are they far from being practical you
know they at least take one of the two
things out of the pictures you have to
worry about the module spend on the ring
are they still are they far from being
practical okay so the modulus if you're
if you're willing to be impractical you
can even less practical you can get rid
of the modulus as well at least in
digital signatures but anyway okay so
that's a that's a good question so
you're talking about these schemes that
sort of don't have an f of X and if you
prove something secure mod F of X and
it's secure this game is secure it's
secure for all right so my so it is
schemes are you know let's say maybe
five to four ten times big longer so my
point of view on that so this is a
personal point of view is that if if
you're really building those schemes and
you want to say I want to be as secure
as X to the n plus one I also be as
secure as X to the N plus X plus one I
want to be also be a suit here is this
um then I think it doesn't make too much
sense because you can just you know how
many different polynomials do you think
are weak right if you know so if you
think you know you try X the n plus when
you try another one then you say okay
those both of those are weak then maybe
there's something wrong with ringing lwe
to begin with right so it doesn't make
sense to say I want to rely on all of
them just rely on a couple of them and
just concatenate that you know we're
work products the n plus one or another
phenomena and just make those two
schemes it'll be more efficient on the
other hand it very well could be that
ring lwe for every polynomial is e is
easy right but they're it's hard so then
it's really not relying on Ringold over
e it's relying on some other different
problem which we haven't really consider
alright so if that's what you
fraida if you're afraid really for all
polynomials then I would say yeah that
makes sense
but if you you're just not sure which
polynomial then I think it doesn't make
too much sense because you can just
concatenate on those I can calculate
those so that's my personal opinion
okay thanks okay so so now all right so
now the rest of the talk will be about
zero knowledge proof use and
applications so I want to say there's a
water as a word of caution right so we
have to be very careful especially we
talk about your knowledge proofs you
know when you claim I have the shortest
lattice based proof right that doesn't
mean that that's very hard claim to make
because there are generic like for
example PCP proofs and you know for
example this Aurora or you can choose
Leggero which can prove lattice
relations right so they can prove
general generic circuits or this r1
CEA's problem and you can embed a
lattice problem into them and they are
actually very succinct so they actually
grow a logarithm clean the number of
inputs so just because you don't use
generic don't use pcps it doesn't mean
that you have the short is proof right
you may have you know there may be a
shorter proof using generic methods so
this is like not a problem for things
like fhe because there's no other way to
do if they achieve other the madison's
but and so you know you can have a court
you know a very inefficient scheme and
still you know and still say this is
very interesting
and but on the other hand for for zero
knowledge you have to be very careful
the DN a-- bush question in the same
vein from one of the participants what
happens when the to break things will be
ideal splits into many small primes
things like so so no I would say no so
none of those papers actually you know
broke the lwe
that that is considered and actually had
a slide on this but I I removed it so
the point is for it so said the question
is the following right so let's say we
take a cue and
the endless X to the D plus one splits
mod Q so now there's a lot of sort of
firm ideals or you know you can always
mod by some some factor of f of X and
now you end up with the lattice of a
smaller dimension but this is where sort
of where the magic of the algebraic
structure comes in that well actually
for first let's say if you just want to
reduce it by a factor by dimension by
two so you find some factor of degree T
over two and you want to mod it there
but you can easily prove that every
factor of degree D over 2 has norm
square root of Q right so you will mod
you will you will reduce the dimension
by half but your coefficients will
increase by square root of Q which is no
quite quite a lot right so it's really
unclear if you're making any progress
there
so I mean so in that sense I would say
that no there hasn't been any any sort
of anything that kind of gets you
worried if you sort of if you said
ultimately if you instantiate W
correctly I haven't seen any attacks
that sort of make me wary of any and
there's good reason for that because
there's the result to break structure
all right so so then the question is
okay so now we have to be careful you
know we have to compete with PCD proofs
so what can lattices offer right now
so what they can offer is shorter proofs
for certain relations so for example the
PCP Babes proofs have a fixed cost right
so they they have some they cannot go
below a certain amount once they reach
that amount they don't go too much above
it but they cannot go below something
and that's about 100 kilobytes for
somewhat acceptable speeds so you can
always make it a little slower and make
it much a little faster and make it
bigger or slower and make it smaller but
you know let's say 100 kilobytes is a
decent is the right to a number
you
okay so and also speed so lattices can
offer speed so lattice schemes are fast
so for example if you go back to lattice
encryption they are actually let's say
five times faster than the best even
discrete log scale so in discrete and
the zero announce groups use the same
operation so on the other hand PCP
schemes are fairly slow they could take
minutes or seconds again depending on
the size of the output to prove lattice
relations so speed and small size is
something that lattices can offer in
certain cases so now in my personal view
again is for ladder zero knowledge proof
to the interesting inside some way I
think you know it should be less than
500 kilobytes and even though that's
still bigger than a PCP thing it's still
interesting because our maybe there's
ways to improve it or maybe it's very
fast or so it should be there preferably
should be better than pcps but you know
at the very least one should acknowledge
the existence of these generic proofs in
terms of speed some theis right so you
just by looking at lattice based proofs
it's not enough because you have to
because there are these generic proofs
that you know a lot of interesting work
has gone into them in the last couple of
years to improve them make you faster
things like that so so you say after you
have to be careful all right so then the
question is okay so now we know kind of
what our goal is so but what do we want
to prove in zero-knowledge right so for
starters you know would make sense to
prove the fundamental you know one way
function knowledge of the preimage your
fundamental one way function in in for
lattices is this you're given this T
equals a s and s is small I want to
prove knowledge of s right it seems like
that that should be something useful for
something right so this is the discrete
log equivalent here is that you have G
to the S or some secret s and I want to
prove knowledge of s and for this quick
plug this is very very simple right this
is the snort protocol so I'm dating back
to the 80s so let me actually review it
you know very briefly because the
lattice things are fairly similar and
we'll be building up on this as we go
okay so here's the snore protocol very
fast
so the prover has a G and a secret s the
verifier has a G and this H which is G
to the s and the prover wants to prove
knowledge of s so he picks around them
why he computes teach the why he sends
it the verifier picks a see a challenge
c sends that over i'm going fairly fast
because i hope most of you seen this
many times and then the prover computes
SC plus y so the goal of the point of
the y was to hide SC so it's uniform in
CP so SC plus y is also uniform in CP
now and there's a Z and the verifier
checks that g to the z is HC times
double so correctness it just works
right because you can rewrite Z as SC
plus y and you have G to the SC plus y
is just there c times y and honest
verifies your knowledge you can create
transcripts by generating random season
Z's and then you set your W to the rage
to the quotient G to the Z over agency
because W is deterministic
once you have to the rest a
deterministic and because Z and C are
uniformly random this is exactly the
same distribution as as the honest proof
okay so now let's try the same thing
sorry
let's do a what if this actually prove
extract something so the prover so the
extractor does the following from the
omelet from the prover or some you know
may not who even knows G and there so it
doesn't know g NS doesn't matter right
so the extractor first runs an artist
first runs the prover once and gets the
CWC and z and then he rewinds the prover
and because the challenge space is big
and our successful perverse should be
able to answer more than one distinct
challenge so he answers to the challenge
here I'm with a Z Prime and get another
equation which is G to the Z prime is H
nu prime times W so you get rid of this
w this is just standard extraction and
you end up with G to the quotient over Z
minus Z Prime and C minus T prime equals
H and that's the discrete log right so
and honor you can extract asks from
approver who can win the protocol
okay so that was discreet ash nor very
fast so now let's try the same thing
with lattices right so let's say you
have a s equals T and you want to prove
knowledge of s but here the important
thing is that s has small coefficients
all right so let's try the same zero
knowledge proof so you have a proven who
knows a and s verify who knows T okay so
the prover he generates a why that's the
masking part and well I'll put a times y
the verifier chooses some C in the ring
the challenge see the prover sends s
times C plus y which is Z okay so the
verifier just checks that a times Z
equals TC plus double like for
correctness you can see that it works
out so it's even easier just correctness
here because a times SC plus y is a SC
plus ay Y which is TC plus them
okay but I mean one should see quickly
that things go wrong very fast with the
other properties for example Z should be
should have small coefficients if you
look at the verification equation if you
don't require Z to have small
coefficients that it's very easy to find
the Z that satisfies a Z equals blah
right so Z has to have small
coefficients which is not what what we
needed last time for the first nor there
Z was was you it was arbitrary okay
so Z has to have small coefficients okay
so how do we make sure Izzy has small
coefficients because these SC plus y
well s has small coefficients good but
then C and y should also have small
coefficients okay fine Y and C should
have small coefficients and the verifier
should also check the Z's well okay no
problem but now there's another problem
now the Z equals SC plus y is not
uniform in the ring and so it may leak
information about s so this is an issue
so of course one way to solve that is
just you can make Y exponentially larger
than s times C so this is called noise
drowning but this is inefficient because
the coefficients of everything grow so
sometimes it's it's unavoidable so there
are some schemes not your knowledge ones
but other ones that really cannot avoid
noise drowning but here it is a water
right so here's a better solution so use
rejection sampling to make the
distribution of Z independent events
okay so we want we can't have Z be
uniform and we don't want Z to leak s so
here is just the quick overview of
rejection sampling I don't want to go
into it in this talk that's not the
point
so forget lattices or anything else so
just probabilities you have an access to
distribution G of X but you don't want
to sample from G of X you want to sample
from f of X okay so I mean the the
standard anointment way to do it is you
figure out what is the maximum value of
f of X over G of X for all X in the
domain of G and you let that be M and
then the solution is your sample X from
G
and then you output it with probability
f of X divided by M times G of X right
so this probability is less than 1
that's good and you repeat other so
that's it that that's how you get
distribution F so it's easy to see that
at every try the probability of getting
X is exactly f of X over m which is the
correct scale distribution ok good so
another way to see this is that the
output this f of X actually hides the
original distribution G okay so that's
the normal you want use rejection
sampling the sample from the
distribution here the intuition is you
actually want to hide the original
distribution so now we can do the same
zero knowledge proof but now maybe you
add rejection sampling to the last part
right so here the distribution of Z of G
of Z yeah
depends on s so this is like the G that
we had in the previous example right so
you have SC plus y that somehow it
depends on s and that's bad but we want
to output a distribution that doesn't
depend on and so here's where you pick
the distribution that you want you hope
you can get it and you do rejection
sampling to get it right so I'm not
going to go into it but there are many
ways to do it right you can try for a
uniform distribution where each
coefficient is random between negative R
and R you can aim for a Gaussian
distribution which is which results in
somewhat smaller seeds sometimes you can
get a bimodal Gaussian distribution
makes even smaller Z's so here I've been
to the line of research here was to sort
of pick a distribution that we can
achieve and try to achieve it with the
rejection sampler so and sort of the
best we could do it it's compatible is
this bimodal Gaussian again doesn't
matter the point is that we can get a Z
to be only let's say square root of the
dimension bigger than s instead of with
noise drowning it would have been
exponentially larger than s so this is
useful for to keep the size of the
output small
so and the extraction so now the
interesting part is extraction so so the
rejection sampling just believe me it
works it's not very interesting if it's
not for the point of this not not not
for this time okay so now what happens
in the extraction so let's say there's a
prove or that can win the game we rewind
them right just like before
so we obtain two equations if we have a
is equal to TC plus W an AZ prime equals
T C prime plus that just like before we
you subtract the two and we end up with
a times Z minus Z prime equals T times C
minus C Prime now in discrete log we
just divided and we achieved
we got a pre-image but here it does not
make too much sense to divide so here's
the reason I mean you can divide by C
minus C Prime but first it may not be
invertible and second even if it is
invertible the quotient may not
necessarily be small so what you wanted
to prove is that you know a short
preimage of t so a times something
equals t but instead you prove something
very different
it's a times something big equals T and
that's not particularly interesting so
dividing so going during the second step
the dividing does not make too much
sense but the proof of knowledge that we
do obtain which is a times something
equals T times something because the
both of these some things are have to
have small coefficients this is
meaningful right and this is useful and
we will sort of build on things use it
so we'll call that a relaxed zero
knowledge proof
it doesn't quite prove what we want but
it proves something a bit weaker okay
so here's here's what happens so the
prover knows a linear relation ase
that's T but he can only prove knowledge
he cannot prove that he knows this but
he can prove knowledge of a small C and
the larger Z such that a is equal C T
okay so this is what we just this is
what we just saw that the Shannara type
protocol gives us all right so what is
that useful for well this is actually
useful for signatures and this is how
the hmm
teachers are get constructed so the
proofing tuition is actually quite
simple
so suppose the public key is 80 the
scheme is zero knowledge and that
adversary you know after seeing
signatures can produce a solution a Z
equals T C so we can extract something
from the adversary who is a successful
signer this Z and C so that a is equals
T C okay great well because the public
key is a and T and a s equals t we can
substitute a s 40 and we get a Z equals
a times s C and subtracting you have a
times Z minus s C equals 0 which is a
solution to sis so and because s is
hidden from the adversary it's not
unique Z minus SC is not 0 so it's over
it's a nonzero solution to this right so
so this is sort of an example where okay
even though we didn't really prove what
we wanted that a s equals T the thing
that we did prove is still useful and we
can get digital image from so ok so
these relax your knowledge groups are
useful but they're not really useful for
other applications for example proving
that the cipher text is proper because
it's proper ciphertext it really Hayes K
s equals t t is the cipher text if you
prove that you know a small s small Z so
that a Z equals some multiple of T well
multiple of T is a proper ciphertext not
not not not T all right so that's not
very useful right so okay we can build
signatures but not it's not really what
we what we were after
okay so but very recently the last
couple of years last year or to continue
now this these relaxed proofs have
actually led to what we want so let me
go through what the sort of what the
plan or what what the roadmap was to
getting something useful beyond
signatures ok so so we have these
approximate proofs
so given a s equals T we can prove that
a s prime equals TC 4 not quite s enough
quite ok
and like I showed in the previous slide
this gives you digital signatures and
again here you know it's not good enough
to get the best lattice basic meters
because you can get signatures from hash
functions so that they are very short
right so they're about three kilobytes
for about 128 bit of security right so
once you optimize and you know the
optimizations a lot of optimizations so
you can get you know yeah so this is
better than generic constructions okay
so that's digital signatures I would say
that's so so you could also get
commitments so some worker from two
years ago you can commit to messages in
are so messengers in the ring and you
can also zero in zero knowledge prove
linear relations between the messages
but the linear relations are over this
ring okay so you could do that that's
also good and this I'll show it later
it's very simple and then what I thought
was family good we finally got what we
wanted using this idea and also some
ideas from you know that were used in
the discrete log proofs for for
zero-knowledge
kind of sort at the same time two papers
appeared that kind of gave almost very
similar in intuitive construction for
how to get exact proofs
so you what you have an S so you use
this commitments key and then using this
commitment scheme you can reduce that
more stuff and then you can really prove
that a s equal you know and ask that a
is equal States really exactly the
exactly what we were after and the
output was about 300 kilobytes I mean
maybe a little more a little less prefer
first or natural instance that we would
use it and the encryption okay so that's
sort of that's a good first step so
something is doable so now on to the
more recent work so this is something
that we've done okay so now you so
before we had you can prove linear
proofs of for this commitment scheme but
now we can do multiplicative group so we
can prove multiplicate relation between
committed values so that's useful and
once you have that
so extension of that is now you can get
what what they called unstructured
probes so these are instead of linear
proofs being over the ring over this
polynomial ring now you can actually get
linear proofs over the integers for the
commitment schemes the commitments could
be over rings but you can prove stuff
over the coefficients of the Rings so
that and I'll sort of explain why that's
interesting and from that you can get
exact proofs again and now you've kind
of decreased the size so now instead of
feeling two kilobytes it's about 50
kilobytes so it's a useful thing to have
and then another thing you can do once
you have multiplicative groups and these
unstructured proves is you can do proofs
of integer relations so for example I
mean we don't really want to prove
relations over polynomials I mean
polynomials are not realistic area I
never I mean it's not a real real life
scenario where you you commit to two
polynomials and you've proved you know
that that you have their product but
integers does make sense right you may
want to prove addition of integers or
multiplication of integers and so this
is what you can do once you have
multiple ikut of proofs and unstructured
proofs
so for in so in this talk the remainder
of this talk I will go into what you
know I'm sort of going to how you can
use multiplicative proofs and then
structure proofs and show what they are
if define more precisely what they are
how to do useful things with them right
and then afterwards Gregor will actually
show the math the guts of how you build
multiplicative proofs and these
unstructured proves so I guess now it's
a decent time for questions before I
if there are any questions so please
write them in the Q&A thing or if your
panelists you can ask them directly and
I think Vadim will take like a two three
five minutes break people I don't know I
can go on okay okay B maybe I'll do
maybe I'll do something a little bit you
know messy and then we'll take a break
after the mess because right now there's
not much to rest from I would say so I
guess the goal of the talk is to explain
what it is we can prove four commitments
and why it's interesting okay so that
that's what's going to be for the
remainder of the alright so
okay so now I'm going to describe what
is this commitment scheme so it's very
simple it's actually very very soon so
the idea is the following you have two
matrices a and B so these are the
matrices you use for to commit and then
to commit to a message M any message in
our queue so it doesn't have to be small
you pick a small R and you multiply your
matrix by R and then you add em to the
bottom part okay so at the end your
commitment is TA and TB so ta is the
part that corresponds to a times R and T
B is B times R plus M all right so why
is this hiding well
it's hiding because we assume lwe it's
hard during a little use harder this
knapsack problem is hard that that a a B
times R is indistinguishable from
uniform
okay so it's hiding because of that and
now so what is opening so to open you
just reveal a small R right so and once
you're revealing are the M is implicitly
TB minus V R right because they can once
you reveal and are the M is completely
fixed once if you know TB v + R M is TB
- dia okay so opening is that so why is
it binding well suppose that there are
two R's that are valid openings are an R
Prime and so you have a R equals t a
equal to a R Prime
well this implies that a times R minus R
prime is zero which is a solution to
this okay so it's very very simple and I
think this is lattice instantiation of
another very old discrete log ski but
it's a very useful for lattice or the
the important feature of this is that
you commit to M with any sort of the
coefficients are not don't have to be
small they can be any any size
coefficient so this is important all
right and so but we want to prove that
we know M right this is the main this is
the the main use of this commitments key
right we commitment schemes by
themselves are not very interesting if I
one of the commitment scheme I would
just use sha
right but I want to prove something
about this commitment you know prove
something prove that I know the M all
right so how do with the proof of
knowledge go so I want to prove that I
know the are that satisfy as a R equals
ta okay good
so I'm gonna use this so this looks very
similar to what we were trying to prove
before and we failed right we tried to
prove that I know a small preimage but
we could only prove that I know a
somewhat small Z and a small C so that a
is equal C times ta right this was the
zero knowledge proof that led to an
efficiency so that's what we can prove
okay I mean that's fine let's say we
prove that right now here is where the
invertibility of C is gonna be important
if c is invertible in our Q then we can
in our there's no our Q it just are
right V equals E over C so just define
B is Z over C and so what we are able to
prove knowledge of is that if we're
given a R equals ta using that protocol
from before we were able to prove a
knowledge of the an arbitrary size of V
so it's not small at all and the small C
with small coefficients such that a
times V equals ta and VC is small okay
so if we were able to really prove
knowledge of ours of a articles ta we
would just prove that we know in our set
a R equals T a and then R is small but
we can't do that so instead we prove
knowledge of an arbitrary be arbitrary
length three there's no restriction on
its length that satisfies HV equals T a
which by itself would be easy but we
also prove knowledge that there's a
small C so that VC is small
okay so together these two things
together actually do do prove that we
know em okay and here's why so to open
you reveal the NC
and so the M as before or is implicitly
TP minus V V
okay so basically I say look the the V
the only V that you know could have been
picked is this one
well once that's the only B that
satisfies a V equals ta then M is fixed
to be TB minus B okay all right so now
we're going to prove binding why why is
this binding suppose there are two
openings for different V's right that
lead to different MS suppose this is a
commitment to the different messages
which means that the V's must be
different okay well this cannot happen
here is why let's go slowly so if there
are two different V's then a V equals t
equals a V Prime and now you multiply
both sides by C times C Prime okay so we
did that and then we subtract one side
from the other to get a times C V C
prime minus C prime V prime C equals
zero okay and this is a solution to sis
so why is it small and nonzero well so
it's easy to see why it's nonzero
because C and C prime are invertible so
you can just divide out by C Prime and V
minus V Prime you know they're different
so that that's not zero okay and why are
they small well they're small because V
times C is small and V prime time C
prime is one
and so they all have these have small or
coalition's okay so it is a proof of
and we're ghosts right so
now this is of course not as good as
just being able to prove a articles ta
and this is sort of let me explain by
parameter setting so this is where
parameter setting is useful and to
understand how to set parameters so
recall what we want we want hiding and
for this you want a B times R to look
random okay and then we also want
binding and there the binding said if
you can if you can open to two different
there messages then you can solve sis
remember a times the CVC prime minus T
prime B prime C is zero right so now if
you just compute the nor the how big it
is this Y is which I defined to be CBS
and prime is U prime B prime C well it's
about square root of M deep times bigger
than R okay so okay so I guess I have a
question that says if a is chosen by the
committer so no a is not chosen by the
committee right so this is very
important a has to be fixed some some
public R and at this a a definitely
cannot be chosen later so right so
basically hiding depends on the fact
that a B times R looks random and
binding depends on the fact that you
can't sell you can't find a y that's
somewhat bigger than R but then the
solution to says knapsack so now if we
go back to this picture right of hiding
and binding so how do you set your
parameters right so you want to first
set some parameter R there's okay so
there's right so mehdi is asking if both
hiding and binding a computational so
they could be but so what I'm gonna show
now that this is not the right way that
wouldn't be the optimal way to set
parameters right so
so sorry sorry no no they are sorry
hiding and binding are both
computational yes correctly correctly so
hiding is right delivery and binding is
cysts oh yeah use a computation you
can't set one of them to be statistical
but that wouldn't be the best way to set
parameters good so right so now you pick
some norm of our yeah so you pick it you
pick something and that's gonna be
somewhere on this curve right maybe you
want to pick it to be at the highest
point you want it to be in the stable
from hiding to be as hard as possible
but unfortunately that the difference
between what you have and what you can
prove is about a factor of square root
of MD so the vector is gonna be big so
the binding is going to become easier
you can also want to make binding as
hard as possible but then hiding is
going to be easier so you have to make
kind of make use of this hump in the
middle and you want to set hiding and
binding to be kind of approximately the
same so that's why hiding should be on
the lwe side and then before the hub and
then the binding should be on the Syst
side after the hump and sort of as as
many said both of these become
computation if you want one to be
statistical then you have to you end up
with an easier to break over all schemes
so if you you have to set higher
parameters to get the same computational
hardness okay so this is kind of where
this is this this gap in what you can
prove comes in when setting parameters
in things like signature schemes and and
commitment schemes right for for
encryption this is kind of it doesn't it
doesn't really make sense it's not
really useful because there everything's
injected for correctness you need
injective but when you don't then you
kind of have this this if to understand
that there's this hub between all of the
incidents and you set the crowd you set
your parameters to be on either side
okay
all right so then now invertibility was
important right so now so because we
needed this C to be invertible because
then our RS our commitment scheme was
binding all the if she wasn't work
really we really relied on that so now
we have to understand what invertibility
and are means so the point is that it is
so you can set your Q so this is where
setting q is important so this is a
necessary a sufficient but not necessary
condition for X to the D plus 1 to split
into irreducible factor so if Q is you
know some prime that is 2 K plus 1 mod 4
K then we can we know exactly X and D
plus 1 splits in this particular way
into K irreducible factors ok in this in
this way so like I said sufficient but
not necessary okay so that shows how
this splits and so now if we look at the
coefficient representation of any
element
in it addition is coefficient wise but
in the Chinese remainder representation
of the entity representation that I will
call it this is the that this
representation is basically a mod one of
the factors of X to the +1 a mod another
factor so basically K polynomials of
degree D over K minus 1 so that's the
Chinese remainder representation of the
same polynomial a and so and this is
useful for many many things and it's
also useful to sort of understand
invertibility and here addition and
multiplication is coefficient wise so
what this means is because
multiplication is coefficient wise this
immediately means that an element and r
is invertible if and only if it's entity
representation has no zeros because if
it if it doesn't have any zeros and you
can always find an inverse because these
are these polynomials are irreducible so
they may induce a field right so there's
no zeros you can always find an inverse
or you just find an inverse for each
individual polynomial and that gives you
the inverse of the whole name right so
an element in R is invertible if and
only if it's entity representation has
no zeros ok so now we want our
challenges or our differences of
challenges to always be invertible the
things we extract so how do we do this
well there are two ways one is that you
can set your ring so that you can prove
that all polynomials with small norms
are invertible so this is this sort of
you can prove something like this it's
not hard to prove so basically if X the
D plus 1 splits into a few irreducible
factors with say 8 or 16 point or usual
or normal parameters then all
polynomials would let's say with
negative 1 0 1 coefficients will be
invertible now this depends on Q as well
but something like this so you can prove
something like that um good but I want
for reasons I have not yet explained I
want X the d+ want to split a lot as
much as possible so again for people who
are familiar with fhe it's it's for this
it's for some very similar reasons is
because I want these slots
to do operations so I want how can I
make it split more well you can actually
prove that the probability that a random
polynomial in R with negative 1 0 1
coefficient hits any particular entity
value is very small so they're actually
kind of well distributed so for example
you know for if Q is 2 to the 32 and it
splits into another degree for that it
really is almost 2 to the minus 128
chance of a small polynomial hitting any
element mod that ring so what this means
is that two values in the extraction
aren't unlikely to collide and the
difference will be invertible not every
X to the fourth - alright okay so this
is using some fourier techniques and
yeah so that this this is better right
this just says that hey look if it just
splits into large enough degrees then
you should be able to you will not see
these challenges are going to be kind of
uniform mod mod the entity coefficients
and therefore you will not get the
difference of challenges to be
invertible to ever be 0 but and so
therefore the extract that C will be
inverted so and this is this is what we
want okay so I I guess I could stop now
for 5
so yes again the the now would be a good
time for a question for questions if
anybody has a communication thing I mean
when you prove that a random polynomial
small polynomial it's put in any
particular then and then you'll apply it
to things that come out of the
extraction why are these random so
because well the challenges are random
because we're considering on aspirin for
zero knowledge because we really care
about the heme R transform of it and
then they are really are random right so
there are some situations where we're
you know you're not using zero knowledge
groups and then the adversary can be
made the adversarial in choosing the
seeds and they're then you cannot apply
this but if but in this situation we're
really there is your approver himself is
controlling the C's thank you so let's
take like a three minute break so that
the Redeem can catch his breath and and
the rest of us and continue
we paddy this is who take on sighs
question on the previous slide I'm also
a little bit confused because the X
function roughly corresponds the
soundness right so what the extraction
corresponds to stylus maybe so suppose
you have a three brick stylus with
probably epsilon then then it's really
only answering the challenges correctly
on some tiny epsilon fraction of the
inputs so it could be that is this
epsilon fraction is bias on the
polynomials that are not invertible it's
not just a hypothetical thing there
really are attacks that could work this
way I see so how is it helpful that or
neither random polynomials have
invertible so okay so let's forget
extraction right let's just say the
adversary he says look I'm looking for a
particular C I'm looking for a
particular entity coefficient I don't
know I want the first entity coefficient
to be something right and then I will
then I will kinetic an answer right but
kind of the prove the the may the main
what you can prove is that actually see
the first entity coefficient there is no
you know any any put any and coefficient
has at most two to the minus 120 a
chance of being hit by any C so the
adversary will be waiting you know more
than one over it sound this time hmm for
that coefficient I see but what you're
saying is exactly the attack that can
happen in real life that he really can
only answer queries that first you know
there are this particular entity cough
it is this particular and then he can
cheat
on that
so the question is what are the factors
of X to the X to the D plus 1 mod a Q
that's a power of 2
yeah I don't know you should ask the
people who go work on I don't know if
rains here or anyone the people who were
submitted sabor this is their team or or
even at the FA I don't know I pay Qi I
mean that they cheese done in this in a
similar ring maybe Xiao Yue Yue and if
someone knows what the factors of this
look like so
I mean III I don't know what the answer
right is but this is always with this
this Q was always to me I thought was
was easier to break but I have no
there's really no reason why I should
think so so but yeah I always yeah this
is the one that bothered me the most
especially because for example if Q is 2
and the LPN problem is becomes sub
exponent becomes some exponential but
look you bigger than 2 I don't know it
always bothered me but I don't know I
wouldn't bet that there's something else
I don't know maybe Christmas so this not
something that can be proved they using
one of these ring leftover harshly I'm a
dipole you're talking about about mom
oddly polly mod the and the entity
coefficients no no right because no at
least I don't see how because there's no
there's no family of functions here
right it's that excellent or minus R
right a lot of random R but but it's
simply it's it's just using Fourier
techniques because if you can think of
it as a stochastic process and then it's
sort of quite I think we can continue
okay Oh
so now okay so this so what I did before
is basically with the commitment scheme
and now here are some things you can
approve acknowledge that I know the
message okay great you know the message
but this is not interesting I'm not too
interesting you actually want to prove
that you know that the message satisfies
some relations okay so the first thing
and this is this is easy proof of
knowledge of linear relations so I again
I have my commitment a BR plus zero M
equals ta TV so it's a commitment and I
want to prove that I know m and that L
times M equals you so you can be public
and L is public L is a matrix of
polynomials in R right and so I want to
prove that I know basically this is m
and it satisfies LM equals
okay so this is just a linear relation
over the ring so as it turns out this is
quite easy to prove and it doesn't it
doesn't increase the size of the proof
you so that's that's fairly nice so the
prover does the following and this is
actually almost exactly like just a
regular proof that your knowledge proof
that we saw before where that was used
for you know will result in the relaxed
extraction but in the green green I will
sort of point out the things that are
and are different that you need for this
different L right the rest
actually just proved that I know and are
and and the and the green stuff is this
particular deal okay so I basically pick
a spica Y then compute a times y and
also compute L times B Y okay and I send
both of them to the verifier so I know I
said that the proofs do not get bigger
but here there's a WB but really doesn't
because in the non interactive protocol
you don't send this part the these are
computed from the other two values or
you if you can think about you can send
the hash of this and you can vary with
the verify I can check the hash so it
doesn't matter if I send waw be there
never really sent
in the actual proof okay so but you know
for simplicity let's say they are sent
the verifier does the same thing as
before it sends this challenge and the
prover react responds with RC plus y
let's see right okay so without the
green stuff that's the proof of
knowledge of it okay so now the verifier
checks that z is small a z equals c ta
plus WN e and this green part which is L
times B Z equals C times the difference
was WV so okay this is just Bessie and
maybe it's not super trivial because
like when I try to reconstruct it myself
it usually takes time so I always look
it up but and I don't think it's that
intuitive unless you really stare at it
for a while so I'll just go through it
quickly you don't have to really
understand that the point is that all
this requires is an extra verification
step right so the only thing so it's the
same proof as knowledge of M but there's
this green part for your testing that L
times M equals Q right so basically when
you extract or rewinding you have a Z
you basically extract something and then
you extract something green you rewrite
a V equals T and then you have L you
also rewrite the other one l times TB
minus DV is you well as we remember
before a V equals I guess TA and TB
minus DV is the implicit message M so
he'll M equals u okay anyway it doesn't
matter I mean this is obviously way too
fast and if I don't think it's very
instructive to go through what happens
the point is that it can be done it's an
it's a simple proof and there's not much
to it so here we're just kind of adding
to our arsenal of things that we can do
the demon question the linear
relationship is here over the ring mod Q
over the ring mod Q over the ring what
okay
so once you have this there's still not
much you can do it's not very useful for
things but it can be used to build more
stuff and but in this outbreak a note
with just one extra commitment you can
be secretive here is going to is public
that you can make it secretive okay and
this is gonna be really what Gregor
talks about in the next talk how to
build these more powerful proofs and I
will just explain how to use this linear
proof together with these powerful
proves to build some very useful things
okay so here are the more powerful
proofs that sort of are not linear
didn't know how to do so let's say you
have commitments to M 1 M 2 & 3 and you
want to prove that m1 times m2 equals M
3 so this is a multiplicative relation
and intuitively this is obviously very
useful because you know if you are
certain circuits they have addition they
also have multiplication right so you
want to prove okay now the other one is
kind of maybe more interesting so let's
say you're given a commitment to m and n
so polynomials M in the ring and N in
the ring and I'm just going to write
them as M 0 plus M 1 X plus all the way
up to M V minus 1 X to the D minus 1 and
a public matrix in zqd by D and so what
I what you can what you want to prove
and maybe it seems a little weird right
now and why would you want to prove but
actually you can prove that L times the
coefficients of M are the coefficients
of it
so you can kind of prove that yeah some
some sort of linear relation over the
coefficients of the polynomial so this
is very very different than then what we
could prove before with linear relations
because here before the linear relation
was over the reign here it's over zq and
it's proving some some yeah relation
over the coefficients of the polynomial
but it turns out that this is very
useful so then so now for the rest I
will show how to use these three things
multiplicative relations these proof of
unstructured relations and the linear
relation to do some interesting in
practice may be things so the linear
relation was a special case for this
unstructured thing right our thing is
truly wider yeah
but believe the proof of the linear
relation is more efficient it's slightly
more but yeah good okay so here's
building up from from somewhat in from
not very interesting to interesting
all right let's say I want to commit to
a message with zero one coefficients
okay and I want to prove to you that the
one I committed to actually has zero 1
coefficients okay so let em so so and
the coefficients are going to be in the
entity okay so let so the code in the
entity I have 0 1 okay so now let the
message in the ring be such that it's
Chinese remainder entity coefficients
are 0 1 integers so then I commit to him
right so using the usual commitment
right here the CITV and now once
somebody has TA and TB they can
themselves create a commitment to n
minus 1 just by subtracting 1 from the
TV part
right because remember TB is just B
times R plus M so if you subtract one
well that's a commitment to end - okay
great and now what you want to prove is
the product that the product of the
committed messages of c0 and c1 is 0
because if you prove that that prove
that means that you've proved that the
entity coefficients which are let's say
M 1 through m K and M 1 - 1 M 2 - 1 MK
minus 1 are 0 and the only way this can
happen is if all the mi are either 0 so
this is kind of a standard trick for
proving something 0 1 but you have to
get things into that form okay so this
was easy right so all we did was we
wanted to prove that the message has
zero one entity coefficients so we used
our product proof to prove that the
product is zero and that implies that
the message must have 0 1 okay good so
that's 1 this not very far from it is a
range proof right we want to show that
an integer in binary is between 0 & 2 to
the J well again let's try it m in our
queue in entity form has MK m 2 up to M
1 right so it's binary coefficients are
these so this is almost the same as the
previous proof so now you have a
commitment to this and now you can
create a commitment that has one in the
coefficients basically subtract off 1 if
those coefficients can be either 0 or 1
and you subtract 0 if those coefficients
really have to be 0 and then you prove
that the product of these two
commitments is 0 so what that means is
that the top part can be 0 or 1 but the
bottom part must be 0 right which means
the high the high coefficients must be 0
and the low coefficients are 0 1 which
is arranged okay so again again this is
the not surprising round multiplicative
proof sleet arrangements ok good
so can you go back the previous slide
for one second
yeah okay so what did you prove here you
put you put on that the M was either
zero or one
no no so I can prove that the M was zero
one I prove that all of its entity
coefficients were either zero okay yes I
understand that's what I meant
you mean the bits you up the entity
coefficients right hmm all right so it
doesn't matter if the entity is you know
if it's what sort of field it is I just
proved it at zero the entities are
integer if it splits fully of either
integers at 0 1 if it doesn't split
fully it's still 0 1 indirectly whatever
ring yes okay now going back to the next
slide please
mmm yes so I just proved that some
entity coefficient of 0 1 others must be
0 okay great ok still not particularly
interesting but ok good that there was a
pause here because I forgot to say it
this is where you want this is why I
wanted things to split right because we
can prove these interesting for example
range proofs right so if there weren't a
lot of entity coefficients of the
polynomial X to the D plus 1 didn't
split very much then there wouldn't be a
lot of you know you couldn't really
embed big numbers into it right so I
mean you could but but if it splits a
lot then you can embed big numbers into
it so this is kind of you want to have a
lot of entity coefficients to have a lot
of slots to work with so again this is
very similar to what the fhe people want
in their in their slots ok so now let's
go back to the thing that we want to
prove that's a s equals T so how can we
use these these three multiplicative
proof linear relation proof and and the
other one too to prove that a s equals T
ok so here's how it works so I want to
prove that I know an S with 0 1
coefficients let's say satisfying a s
equals T so here's what I do
first they commit to s and to a message
M
who is NTT are the coefficients of s so
I want to commit to M whose NT in NTT
it's 0 1
okay and those are the coefficients of s
okay
then I want to prove that M has zero one
entity coefficients great so this is
easy what I haven't done yet is proven
that M and M really has the entity
coefficient of s haven't connected them
okay then I prove that a times s equals
T ok great so I have some s a s equals T
I have some M with zero one entity
coefficients what I haven't done yet is
prove that s that s and M are somehow
related right so once I if I can prove
that that the s and M are related in
this exact way that I in one then I'm
done okay
and this is where the unstructured
relation proof comes in so I'm gonna
prove that s is the entity of M and so
as it happens entity is a linear
relation over Z Q right so to use this
vandermonde matrix right so I make that
linear relation that unconstructed
structured Li relation proof I make it
the vandermonde matrix and I prove that
s equal the entity over the ways I use
the multiplicative proof proof of linear
relation and the instructor relation
proof to get exactly what
okay
so this is sort of another use of this
unstructured relation proof like what
can you put into it well you can put the
entity matrix into and then it kind of
proves what we want
it proves basic connection between the
coefficient representation which what
needs to be small for all these as a
knapsack problems and the entity
representation this is what we can prove
efficiently to be small with
multiplicative groups okay so that and
this this linear this entity they spent
on my matrix being able to prove that
one is the entity of the other is what
converts between these two
representations and allows us to to have
a proof okay so that's another
application so then we can also do
integer sounds so now I want to prove
that we didn't see the entity
coefficient proof you can make
everything on interactive yeah
everything can be non interactive so
this is IV I guess Gregor will show all
of all of the proofs in the next next
talk so yes every absolutely everything
is not interactive there's never any
interaction necessary we attach sugar
okay so now integer sums now so let's
say here's what I want and this is now
realistic right so we don't really care
about palaces we just want to prove
integer addition I'm given commitments
to integers M 1 M 2 & 3 written in
binary I want to prove that M 1 plus M 2
equals M 3 all right so let's first look
what what addition looks like in binary
right so let's say I'm adding whatever
these two numbers are in binary right
and I will get this the result and there
is this carry vector on top right so if
you're gonna do schoolbook addition
that's what it looks like all right good
but I'm working with polynomials I can
commit to polynomials so let's look what
if I write the first number in
polynomial form you know so natural way
so zeros and then the second number is
polynomials and then add them together
right well I still get the right answer
in the sense that evaluating this at 2
will give me the correct integer but
that's not really binary right so
whatever M 3 hat is written in it's not
going to be that point but what I can do
is that I can say okay I'm gonna write
it I'm gonna kind of keep moving it into
a equivalent binary for so and the way I
can do it okay I can always subtract a
from add X minus 2 which corresponds to
doing a carry right so if I add X minus
2 this is really like a carry I subtract
2 from the first slot and add it to the
second I can also add x squared minus 2x
right if I need to do a carry or I can
add X cubed minus 2x squared right so
I'm always adding some multiple of X
minus 2 and that's equivalent the
equivalent evaluation of 2 meaning the
binary representation stays the same and
so you get something and you get this
you get this and that's exactly the
answer in binary right so now the
intuition is let C be the carry vector
so as polynomials you can always write
em 3 equals M 1 plus M 2 plus X minus 2
times this carry vector right x whatever
I needed to transform something with the
correct evaluation that 2 into something
that has the same evaluation but has
coefficient 0 1 right so there is some
carry vector which has zeros and ones
which is like that and then that's it
right then we'll kind of apply our three
things so with then we commit to to this
and one and two and three and NC whose
entity coefficients are M 1 M 2 M 3 and
C so we commit to these we prove that
they have 0 1 coefficients that's the
multiplicative proof then we prove that
the NT that really they are the entities
of the correct Mis that's the instructor
relation proof and then we prove that in
its coefficient representation M 3 is M
1 plus M 2 plus X times X plus X minus 2
times C which is the linear relationship
so that the intuition here is that we
want to do operations as polynomials
with coefficients but we want to prove
stuff about these coefficients and in
order to prove stuff about these
coefficients we want to move to the anti
T representation and use the
multiplicative and that's what the
instructor relation proves
okay so that's how you prove into
yourselves now integer products there's
a there's a wrinkle here so let's say
you want to prove that you have
commitments to M 1 M 2 M 3 and you wanna
prove that m1 times m2 is m3 now it's
very very similar very similar in the
intuition right so you have a carry
vector right when you do schoolbook
multiplication but it's no longer a 0 1
carry with because if you do schoolbook
multiplication you can have you can
actually add you're adding a lot of
things together ok but you do it exactly
the same there's a question isn't the
entity matrix into an extension of FQ
how do you deal with okay so I'm not
sure I understand the question but are
you saying if the polynomial doesn't
split completely then what is the entity
matrix or yeah ok good so I'm then it
becomes Messier but you can't you can't
define you can't define it as an integer
particular into your matrix or a
particular form so this is something
that we did but let's for now let's just
pretend it splits completely and it's
it's over the end but yes that's a good
that's a good question but this is
something that yeah um ok so right so
you commit to these guys then you prove
just as before that N 1 M 2 & 3 have 0 1
coefficients but now C does not have 0 1
coefficients as before because the
carries can be bigger than 0 and okay so
she has small coefficients but not very
big but not 0 1 so let's let's kind of
bypass it for now and then the rest is
exactly the same you prove that the
entities of n eyes are M eyes and then
you prove using a linear relation proof
you prove that what you want okay so the
only difference here is that C does
carry does not have small coefficients
okay so if you're a multiple you know if
you have coefficients if you're
multiplying 32-bit numbers your
coefficients could be you know between 0
your carries could be the chain 0 32 now
what you don't want to do is you don't
want to commit
two large proof large numbers right
because these range proofs get harder
the bigger the numbers are so the proof
grows logarithmically in the range size
which is bad so you don't really want to
end up proving that my in coefficient is
between 0 and 32 right because the proof
becomes much worse but you don't have to
and this is our another application of
this unstructured linear relation so all
we need to do so why do we need to prove
that there the coefficients are small
because what you don't want to happen
you don't want to get a reduction mod Q
because that would just screw everything
up because you're working sort of you're
relating polynomial multiplication over
Z to multiplicative binary
multiplication but if there's a
reduction about Q if you're done right
now it no longer makes sense so all you
have to do is that prove that the
coefficients in C are small enough so
that there's no reduction mod Q ok so
now what we're going to do is a relaxed
range group we're not going to prove
that the coefficients of C are between 0
and 32 we're just going to prove that
they're small enough all right so now
there's a simple lemma that says the
following so suppose you have a vector
an integer vector and in ZK and another
vector in Zn and now you choose U at
random I made around the matrix with 0 1
coefficients then u times Z plus y what
Q cannot be smaller than cannot have
norm smaller than half of C basically
you cannot mouth
apply a big number by around the matrix
and add some you know fixed Y and he
fixed Y to get a small to get the small
to get something small so basically in
the pictures it's like this if I have a
see if I multiply it with a random 0-1
matrix and you know there's a fixed Y
that's the matter you see plus Y cannot
be small if you see is big so basically
if there is out this small see useful so
basically other words if you see plus y
is small then C must be small so now the
important notes so if you're working
over a larger ring the probability does
not become there's not sort of scale
with the with the D it really stays it
to to the minus n so kind of if you work
in a big ring still it doesn't work so
you really need and also taking the
coefficients of you larger than zero one
also does not help so you really need
this and so therefore it's important
that the random matrix U is an integer
matrix
even if working over a larger array but
that's exactly what we can prove again
with these unconstrained linear relation
right so the idea is the following we
have a commitment to C and we want to
prove that it's small so you create a
commitment to Y and send it to the
verifier receive the challenge you from
the verifier you output Z equals you see
plus y and here it's important this is
the reason for why you don't want to
leak C right and U is small here so you
cannot just output u times C so use
rejection sampling to not leak C and
then you use an unstructured relation
proof to show that u times C is really a
commitment to Z minus y right so there's
sort of another way to use this
unstructured relation and you can then
you can show normally of the
coefficients of Seir like 32 then you
know for rejection sampling you know
they'll go up to maybe 64 times m'kay
and which is much less than so it has
sort of nothing to do so no caries
okay so basically with these techniques
with these sort of is it relaxed your
knowledge proofs and things you can do
are you get fairly practical things so
for example this is what really new
digital signatures you know well public
key which is commitment size and
signatures proof size in analogy you
know is one-and-a-half kilobytes and and
the signature is three kilobyte that's
really to get the this this relaxed
proof that we saw in the very beginning
and then the commitment scheme if you
just want to commit to a message and
prove knowledge of it it's about six
kilobytes each if you want to do a range
proof the proof size grows to maybe
seven kilobytes if you want to do a
multiplicative proof while now you're
committing to more things so the
treatment size grows a little bit but
the proof is still reasonably fifteen
kilobytes and if you want to do
multiplication it becomes twenty
kilobytes so I mean caveat is here these
numbers are approximate and could change
this is really ongoing work but yeah so
I mean this is definitely below what you
can get with PC feeds right so there is
something useful here I'm sorry and also
you I want to show that these three
relations you can prove linear relation
multiplicative and unconstrained are
quite quite useful so maybe they'll be
useful for other things so so I think
there's lots of open problems here in
terms of practical things right so if
you include improve this commitment in
this main commitments you might think
you'll end up improving all zero
knowledge groups a little bit if this is
the best way to get them so maybe you
can improve your own spruce without
improving these commitments so these are
just very general questions particularly
insightful and you know you can of
course now start applying these zero
knowledge proves tomorrow fit to get
more efficient blind signatures group
signatures all this stuff that your
knowledge proves are used for so now
this very hard problem I think is to get
practical succinct proofs so kind of
really try to compete with PCP so there
are some sub linear proofs but the noise
grows a lot in these loudest things
there's no bootstrapping type thing so
in terms of getting succinct proofs
where you know the proof size doesn't
increase linearly
this
I don't know I mean it practical right
you can do it asymptotically and you
know how to do it but practically I
don't think this will beat PCP so new
really new ideas will be required here
take the very interesting area of
research and then of course there's this
ROM versus cura
you know one of the appeal of lattices
is that quantum secure but you know the
proof they all have this rewinding right
and the most efficient instantiations
are based on ROM so there's no currently
there aren't many cure improves unless I
mean there are ways to make them cube
secure the cure-all but it's less
efficient so it's unclear if it's you
know it's worth it because so the
question is can we prove their hardness
in the Cure I mean there are some of you
some recent interesting works so mark
will talk about something on Tuesday and
I think another question and this is the
question that I guess you know
reappeared itself for a period you know
thirty years later do we really care
right I mean this was the question
people asked about the ROM before and
then some people showed that maybe it
does matter but but then you know it
seems like it doesn't people kind of
accept it but that's not the question is
this cure arm really matter right if we
can produce and we produce any natural
example where a proof in the ROM ends up
being insecure against the quantum
attacker can we do you know does this
exist and that would be very interesting
because that would show that Khurram is
actually important but you know as of
now there's no example whatsoever where
something goes wrong if you don't
consider zero
um okay so that was it then there was a
question PC piece can be used on secret
shared data can we do something similar
so like like PC or would it or is the
question so about secret Sharda is that
can we do MPC or something or lattice
probes
I mean I don't know I don't know so the
only two example I mean this is very
recent work so the only two examples
kind of we had was the natural one
addition and multiplication um I'm sure
that you can do other things I I haven't
I haven't done it yet well one is I'm
not even I don't even know what I don't
know what the questions are so I'm
really looking forward to some talks on
Friday about MPC and fhe and private
information retrieval maybe they're
interesting applications yeah
another question is the commitment
scheme is is a symmetric encryption
based on lwe
so the commitment scheme is a symmetric
encryption meaning that you keep our is
the secret key and a is and you always
change the a and the B right is that the
construction you had in mind
yeah okay we can achieve just based
income W without random Oracle's or
transform so I don't know about these
generic transformations so I have no I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what the implications are of I mean but
nobody thing is the zero knowledge proof
uses a random Oracle right our zero
knowledge proof is in the random Oracle
model so so so I think
the random Oracle model but you can
probably do it better with with with one
of these generic transforms liquid you
see yeah yeah yeah I think the question
we maybe was maybe wasn't obvious that
we were using the random Oracle's in our
proofs but yeah our not interactive
proofs are definitely only the random
Oracle so there is a random Oracle
any more questions okay so thank you
very much with him we'll take a short
break and we'll come back at 1:30 I
think what that is good well 1:30 New
York time so I guess 10:30